The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
As I was getting myself
prepared for the lecture,
an old shaggy dog
science story came
to mind that's usually
told as a tribute
to the German
scientist's thoroughness.
This was the story of when all
the scientists of the world
got together and decided
for an annual project.
Each country would study
exhaustively a different animal
and report at the
end of the year
as to what they had found out.
And at the end of the year,
every country but Germany
had been heard from.
No one knew what had happened
to the German scientists.
And five years later, the German
report came in, a huge epitome,
and it was entitled, "Handbook
of the Elephant, Volume 1."
And the reason that this story
comes to mind is twofold.
First of all, the
study of vector spaces
has so many ramifications, that
to study the subject thoroughly
should be a full year's
course by itself.
And secondly, with respect to
the particular topic of basis
vectors and spanning vectors,
and whether subelements
are linearly independent,
whereas we've
invented a rather nice row
reduced matrix technique
for finding out what space is
spanned by a set of vectors
and what a basis
for that space is,
frequently we don't want
that much information.
And what I'm leading up to
is a topic which you've all
had in a previous context.
It's called determinants.
And today, what I
would like to do
is to study determinants within
the framework of vector spaces.
And the way it comes
up is as follows.
Suppose we have an
n-dimensional vector space, v,
and suppose that we
pick a particular basis,
u1 up to un, for v itself.
Now, the idea is this.
Knowing that the
dimension of v is n,
we immediately know
that more than n vectors
can't be a basis
for v, because they
will be linearly dependent
rather than linearly
independent.
Fewer than n vectors
of v cannot be a basis,
because fewer than n vectors,
since the dimension is n,
cannot span v. Consequently, the
only point of interest is what
happens when we're given a set
of n vectors and v. Namely,
given the n vectors, alpha
1 up to alpha n and v,
is this set a basis or isn't it?
And rather than to use the row
reduced matrix technique, here
what we're saying
is we don't want,
for example, in many cases,
to know what the betas look
like that we talked
about in our lecture
on spanning vectors
and the like.
All we want to know is,
are these vectors linearly
independent or aren't they?
And so what we do
is we essentially
invent a function machine.
In other words, what
we're going to do
is to construct a
function in which,
given that the dimension of
our space is n-dimensional,
the input of our
function machine
will be any set of n
vectors from that space.
And the machine will
be programmed to give 0
as an output if the vectors
are linearly dependent,
in other words, if they are
not a basis, and non-zero--
and I'll explain in more
detail what non-zero--
why I picked non-zero rather
than a specific non-zero
number--
if the n vectors
do form a basis.
In other words, I
am going to invent
a function, D, capital D, to
indicate the word determinant
here, such that D of the n
vectors, alpha 1 up to alpha n,
will be 0 if and only
if the set of n vectors
are linearly dependent.
Now, obviously, a
function machine
can do nothing by itself.
We have to give--
and I hope this is well-known
by now in our course--
we have to endow
anything that we're
working with with a
particular structure
so that is feels free to
work logically for us.
Well, among other
things, what do we
know for sure is
a set of n vectors
which are a basis for v?
Since we were given that the
specific basis that v is being
referred to with respect
to are u1 up tp un,
then certainly, if u1 up to un
is the input of the D machine,
we want a non-zero output.
For the sake of just
normalizing things,
let's program the machine
so that D of u1 up to un
will be 1.
Now, notice, by
the way, this only
tells us one special basis.
There are many bases that
I could have chosen for v,
and certainly
condition one by itself
isn't going to tell me any--
has no information programmed
in it to tell me
anything other than what
it does to u1 up to un.
As a second input to my D
machine for programming it,
I certainly know that
given the n vectors,
if any two of the vectors
happen to be equal, then
those vectors are
linearly dependent.
Consequently, I
instruct my D machine,
that if the input is a set of
vectors alpha 1 up to alpha n,
and at least two of
the alphas are equal--
and the way we say
that mathematically
is that alpha i equals alpha
j for a sum i unequal to j--
that if two of the vectors
in the set are equal,
we tell the machine to
grind out 0 as an output.
And by the way, at
this stage we should
be very careful to
recognize that this is not
the only way in which
a set of vectors
can be linearly dependent.
There are many ways in
which a set of vectors
can be linearly dependent,
even if no two of the vectors
are equal.
So consequently, given
a linearly dependent set
of vectors in which
no two are equal,
notice that condition two
here will not work or do
anything for me.
So all I have done by
conditions one and two
is I have endowed my D
machine with two standards.
One particular case in which
the output of the D machine
will be the number 1, and
a particular situation
in which the output of
the D machine will be 0.
But I have not
solved the problem
that I wanted so far,
namely, to make sure
that D grinds out 0 if and
only if the set of n vectors
are linearly dependent.
Let me now endow D
with a third property.
It is a property that will
suggest linearity to you,
and it's one which is
amazingly powerful.
And what I mean by
amazingly powerful hopefully
will become clear
in a few moments.
But the third property is this.
And rather than
work with n-tuples
here, to make things
easier to read,
let me just take a
3-tuple over here.
Suppose I have a
three-dimensional vector space,
and I pick three
vectors in that space.
Suppose one of those
vectors-- the way
I've written that
here, it happens
to be the second vector.
Suppose one of those
vectors is itself written
as a sum of two other
vectors in the space.
Then I tell the D machine
to compute this as follows.
Linearize this, in other
words, compute this
as if it were the sum of two
separate determinants, one
of which had the alpha 2
missing, and the other of which
had the beta 2 missing.
In other words,
what I do is is I
endow the machine
with the property
that D of alpha 1 comma, alpha
2 plus beta 2 comma, alpha 3
will be D of alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3 plus D
of alpha 1, beta 2, alpha 3.
And thirdly-- well, thirdly.
I don't mean thirdly.
I mean the other
lineal property.
If one of the input vectors
is multiplied by a scalar,
I can factor the scalar out.
In other words, if the three
vectors that are being tested
in my three-dimensional
space have the form alpha 1,
c alpha 2, and alpha 3, D of
alpha 1 comma, c alpha 2 comma,
alpha 3 will be--
see, factor of the c out.
c times D of alpha
1, alpha 2, alpha 3.
And it's extremely important
to notice that the c does not
have to be a scalar multiple of
all three vectors in the input.
Notice, that the
fact that the c was
multiplying one of the vectors
is enough to factor the c out.
Without belaboring this
point, all I wanted to say
was, that if the c were
multiplying each of the alphas,
in other words, if this
were D of c alpha 1 comma,
c alpha 2 comma, c alpha 3, this
would equal c cubed D alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3,
because we would
fact about the c each time--
one for each vector.
But let me illustrate this
in terms of a 2 by 2--
a two-dimensional
example for you.
Suppose I'm dealing in
two-dimensional space,
and I'm dealing with respect to
a particular basis, u1 and u2.
And let's suppose that relative
to that basis, u1 and u2,
alpha 1 is the
vector 3 comma, 1,
beta 1 is the vector
6 comma, 7, and beta 2
is the vector 4 common, 5.
Let's recall the fact
that, one way or another,
we already know how to
expand 2 by 2 determinants,
even though we may
not know rigorously
why the rules were chosen.
The idea is, what would
alpha 1 plus beta 1 be?
It would be the 2-tuple whose
first entry was 3 plus 6
and whose second
entry was 1 plus 7.
In other words, the first
row of the determinant
that I'm going to be talking
about has as its entries
3 plus 6 and 1 plus 7.
Beta 2, which will make up the
second row with my determinant,
has as its components 4 and 5.
So the second row of
my determinant is 4, 5.
And using the usual rule for
multiplying determinants,
this is 5 times 9 minus
4 times 8, which is 13.
And by the way, just to
refresh your memories here,
what if I computed in terms of
my D language and the alpha 1,
alpha 2, and beta
2 is used here?
This is D of alpha 1 plus
beta 1 comma, beta 2.
On the other hand, what would
D of alpha 1, beta 2 be?
D of alpha 1 beta
2 would be the 2
by 2 determinant, whose
first row was 3, 1,
and whose second row was 4, 5.
D of alpha 1, beta 2
would be the determinant
whose first row--
I'm sorry.
D of beta 1 comma, beta 2,
would be the determinant
whose first row was 6, 7 and
whose second row was 4, 5.
In other words, these matrices
here, what is this again?
This is D of alpha 1, beta 2.
And this one here is
D of beta 1, beta 2.
And notice, that
this determinant
by the traditional way
of expanding is 11.
This determinant is 30
minus 28, which is 2.
11 plus 2 is 13.
And we see that, at least
in this case, D of alpha 1
plus beta 1 comma, beta
2, is the same as D
of alpha 1 comma, beta 2 plus
D of beta 1 comma, beta 2.
So at least the first
part of property three
is obeyed in this
particular example.
And to show what the
second property is,
let's suppose alpha 1 now--
I pick a new alpha 1.
We'll call that 2 comma, 6.
Suppose alpha 2 is 3 comma, 4.
Then the determinant of alpha
1 and alpha 2 would be what?
2, 6, 3, 4.
And that's what?
8 minus 18, which is minus 10.
On the other hand,
notice that a common--
that this vector
here could have been
written as twice 1 comma, 3.
I can, therefore,
factor out the 2.
See, notice this very carefully.
Notice that the alphas, which
are written in a row here--
one row this way--
each alpha forms a row when I
use the matrix interpretation.
So what I'm saying is, that
2 comma, 6 is one vector.
It's a 2-tuple with respect
to the basis u1 and u2.
All I'm saying is factor out
the 2 from the first row,
from the first vector.
That leaves me with 2
outside, 1, 3, 3, 4 inside.
And notice, that 4 times--
4 minus 9 is minus 5
times 2 is also minus 10.
Notice that these, indeed,
are equal, and notice
that I could factor out the 2
simply by virtue of the fact
that it was a common
factor in one row.
It did not have to be a
common factor in both rows.
In fact, if it had been a
common factor in both rows,
I would have had to
factor out a 2 twice,
in other words, a 4 over here.
Now, I can go on with
things like this,
but, again, I want to
stress the overview.
And the key point is that these
three simple properties, which
I've just called simply one,
two, and three, those three
properties that I've
programmed the D machine with
are enough to
completely determine
D. In other words, if I wanted
to be dramatic over here,
the key point is that one, two,
and three completely determine
D. I'll put an exclamation
point down there.
Because what I claim is, that
once these three properties are
obeyed, there is no
possible way for D
to behave other than in a
very unique well-defined way.
That D now has a perfectly
well-defined structure.
Let me give you some
examples of that structure.
I'll just prove a
couple of theorems.
I'll prove them in
two-dimensional space,
leaving it for the
exercises to work
on higher dimensional space, but
this doesn't get too cluttered.
First of all, what I claim
is that the D machine
is so finicky, that
if you interchange
the order in which the
two vectors are given,
you change the
sign of the output.
In other words, D of alpha
1, alpha 2, in that order,
is the negative of D
of alpha 2, alpha 1.
And the proof, again,
follows very nicely
in terms of our game structure.
The gimmick to begin with is
that we must be clever enough
to decide that we'll compute
the determinant of alpha 1
plus alpha 2 comma,
alpha 1 plus alpha 2.
On the one hand, by
our second property,
since two of the vectors
making up the set being tested
are equal, it means that
that determinant must be 0.
On the other hand,
by property three,
by linearity, splitting
this up as two terms,
notice that this is D of alpha
1 comma, alpha 1 plus alpha 2
plus D of alpha 2 comma,
alpha 1 plus alpha 2.
In other words,
this result here.
Now, in turn, noticing
that these form a sum,
I can rewrite this one as what?
D of alpha 1 comma, alpha 1 plus
D of alpha 1 comma, alpha 2.
This one is D of
alpha 2 comma, alpha 1
plus D of alpha
2 comma, alpha 2.
I've just written this whole
thing out on this next line.
By property two, D of alpha
1 comma, alpha 1 must be 0.
D of alpha 2 comma,
alpha 2 must be 0,
because after all, you see,
two vectors are equal in this.
So what do I have left?
Comparing this with this, I have
the D of alpha 1 comma, alpha 2
plus D of alpha 2
comma, alpha 1 is 0.
And that means that the
number-- and keep that in mind,
the determinant is a number.
It maps the n vectors
into a number, which
is either 0 or non-zero.
But the determinant of
alpha 1 comma, alpha 2,
therefore, must be the negative
of the term of alpha 2,
alpha 1, because their sum is 0.
The second theorem--
and this is the one
that relates determinants to
matrices, a very fantastic
result, one that has tremendous
practical application that
will also talk about
later in the lecture.
And that is, that if I take
any one of my input vectors
and replace it by itself, plus
a scalar multiple of another,
I do not change the determinant.
In other words, for example,
if I replace alpha 1 by alpha 1
plus a scalar multiple of alpha
2, and I leave alpha 2 alone,
the determinant of
alpha 1 and alpha 2
will be the same as the
determinant of alpha 1
plus c alpha 2 comma, alpha 2.
And again, the
proof is very easy,
namely, look at the
expression D of alpha 1
plus c alpha 2 comma, alpha 2.
Use the linearity
property that this
is D of alpha 1 comma, alpha
2 plus D of c alpha 2 comma,
alpha 2.
Then use the second part
of the linearity property
that the constant factor, c,
can be taken outside here.
So this becomes D
of alpha 1, alpha 2
plus c times D of
alpha 2 comma, alpha 2.
And notice, that since
alpha 2 is repeated here,
this determinant is 0.
And consequently,
what we've proven
is that this is equal to this.
Now, I've just proven
those two theorems,
because that's about all I need.
Let me show you now,
that if I had never
seen that shortcut
method of expanding a 2
by 2 determinant, as
learned in high school,
how these three
properties uniquely
determine what D has to mean.
In other words, why I said that
these three properties uniquely
determine D.
As an example, let me take a
two-dimensional vector space
again.
Let me pick u1 and u2
as a specific basis,
and that's important.
I've picked a specific
basis, u1, u2.
Now, I pick any two vectors.
Since v is a two-dimensional
space, I pick any two vectors--
alpha 1 and alpha 2.
And because of
this notation, this
means that alpha 1 and alpha
2 are both linear combinations
of u1 and u2.
Say alpha 1 is this,
and alpha 2 is this.
Therefore, what is D of
alpha 1 comma, alpha 2?
Well, by direct substitution,
D of alpha 1, alpha 2, just
replace alpha 1 by what
it's equal to here, alpha 2
by what it's equal to here.
And we get that D of alpha 1,
alpha 2 is this expression.
Now, we use the
linearity property.
We treat this as one
number for the time being
and split this up as a sum.
In other words,
it's going to be D
of this term comma, this
whole term plus D of this term
comma, this whole term.
In other words, if I do that,
this breaks down to this.
Now, I notice that
each of these two
is a 2-tuple in which the second
entry is a sum of two terms.
So I now split
this up into what?
D of this comma, this plus
d of this comma, this.
This term becomes D of this
comma, this term plus D
of this comma, this term.
And I hope it
doesn't sound boorish
on my part to keep saying
"D of this comma, this."
I prefer to say that
for you so that you
can watch what I'm
doing, and then
have you just be able afterwards
to read what these things mean.
Now, when I'm down
to here, notice
that by my second
part of linearity
I can factor out
the a11 from here.
I can factor out the
a21, because it's
a common factor of this term.
In other words, I
can write this term
as a11, a21, D of u1 comma, u2.
And again, sparing
you the details,
notice I can factor out an
a11, a22 from this term.
I can factor out an a12,
a21 from this term, an a12,
a22 from this term.
And that this now can be
written in this particular way.
Now, what properties do I
know that D is endowed with?
I know, first of
all, that whenever
D operates on a set of vectors
where at least two of them
are equal, D must
give 0 as an output.
So D of u1 comma, u1 is 0 again.
u1 comma, u2 is the
particular basis with respect
to which I define v, you see.
Therefore, by property one,
D of u1 comma, u2 must be 1.
D of u2 comma, u1 is just the
permuted order of u1 and u2.
Therefore, by our first theorem,
that must be minus D of u1, u2.
Therefore, it must be minus 1.
And finally, D of
u2 comma, u2 is 0.
And if I now collect
everything that I
have left here, what do I have?
I have the D of alpha 1 comma,
alpha 2 is equal to what?
It's equal to a11, a22, see,
times 1, minus a12, a21.
In other words, this
is the determinant
of alpha 1 comma, alpha 2.
And let me, again, put an
exclamation point here.
Because if you now go
back to the high school
way of computing
this determinant--
remember how we did it?
What would we have obtained?
And, again, let me just come
back to this board for a second
here.
Remember how you used the
matrix of coefficients?
So take the determinant,
would be what?
a11, a22 minus a12, a21.
So, again, notice two
things that happen here.
First of all, I
get the same answer
as I would have got
the traditional way.
And second, just
as a minor aside
that I'll emphasize more
later in the lecture
and also in the
exercises, notice
that you can begin to
suspect that the actual value
of the determinant of
alpha 1 and alpha 2
should depend on what
basis was chosen.
Because relative to
a different basis,
notice that the
coefficients might very well
be different for
alpha 1 and alpha 2.
But I don't want to
mention that right now.
I think, as I say,
what the amazing result
is, that what I meant by
saying that these three
properties completely
determine D, is the fact
that with these
three properties it
turns out that the high school
definition was ironclad.
Meaning, there was
no other possible way
to define what the
determinant should
be if you wanted these three
properties to be obeyed.
By the way, I have
some quick checks.
Notice that relative
to the basis
u1, u2, u1 can be
written this way,
u2 can be written this way.
We know that D of
u1, u2 should be 1.
And using the old fashioned
way for checking this,
what would the determinant be?
It would be 1 times 1 minus
0 times 0, which is 1.
Secondly, we also know that
property two should yield 0
as a determinant if these two
vectors that were making up
the input were equal.
Let's call the vectors au1, bu2.
So the 2 by 2 determinant
I would get in this case
is ab, ab.
And if I expand that
determinant, it's what?
a times b minus a
times b, which is 0.
And now, let me come
back to that idea of what
motivated the whole
block of material
here, the trouble with
writing vectors as n-tuples.
That there really is something
that requires great care.
In advanced applications, one
must always be wary of this.
I am not going to give you the
advanced applications here.
All I want you to do
is to become prepared
against the pitfalls.
And the thing is, that in
dealing with determinants,
as I said before, you must be
very, very careful about what
basis you're referring to
for a given vector space.
Obviously, the vectors do
not depend on the basis,
but their representation does.
Let me give you a for instance.
Using v and u1 and u2
as an example number 1,
suppose we let alpha 1 be
the 2-tuple, 3 comma, 4.
In other words, 3u1 plus 4u2.
And let alpha 2 be 2 comma, 5.
Then by what we've just
proven, the determinant
of alpha 1 comma,
alpha 2 must be
the determinant of what matrix?
The one whose first row
is 3 comma, 4, and whose
second row is 2 comma, 5.
If I compute that determinant--
and by the way, notice,
now that I know
that the shortcut
way has to be the
right answer, I
don't do this the
long way anymore.
I just say, OK, it's 3 times
5 minus 2 times 4 15 minus 8,
which is 7.
So the determinant of
alpha 1, alpha 2 is 7.
So far so good.
But let me point out
the following thing.
Notice, that alpha 1 and alpha
2 are also linearly independent.
Namely, 3 common, 4 is not a
scalar multiple of 2 comma, 5.
Consequently, since alpha
1 and alpha 2 our linearly
independent, and since v
is a two-dimensional space,
it means that alpha 1 and alpha
2 are themselves a basis for v.
In other words, v is equal to
the space spanned by alpha 1
and alpha 2 as a basis.
Notice, that relative
to this new basis,
alpha 1 comma, alpha 2, alpha
1 is 1 alpha 1 plus 0 alpha 2,
alpha 2 is 0 alpha
1 plus alpha 2.
And therefore, using
the traditional method
of computing the
determinant, notice
that the determinant of
alpha 1 comma, alpha 2
relative to the basis
alpha 1 and alpha 2
would be what determinant?
It would be to the
determinant of the matrix
whose first row was 1, 0, and
whose second role was 0, 1.
And that is 1.
This looks like a contradiction.
You see, on the one hand,
we have the D of alpha 1
and alpha 2 is 1.
But down here, we just saw that
D of alpha 1 and alpha 2 was 7.
Which is correct?
Well, the answer is,
they're both correct.
That the first observation
is, that if the determinant
of alpha 1 and alpha
2 is not 0, the value
depends on the particular basis.
In other words, if
the determinant is 0,
it turns out that
no matter what basis
you use to represent the
determinant of alpha 1
and alpha 2, you will get
0 once the terminator is
0 in one basis.
And if the determinant
is not 0 with respect
to a particular basis, it
will be non-zero with respect
to all bases.
But what non-zero number it will
be does depend on the basis.
And that was why way
back at the beginning
we told the D machine simply
to give a non-zero output
if the input was a set of n
linearly-independent vectors.
In summary, when one says that
the determinant of alpha 1
and alpha 2 is 7,
it's tacitly assumed
that D is being referred to with
respect to the particular basis
u1, u2.
On the other hand, when one says
that D of alpha 1 and alpha 2
is 1, it's tacitly
assumed that the basis
that we're using to express
v is alpha 1 and alpha 2.
Again, I'll drill that
more in the exercises.
Let me go on now
to generalize what
happens in n-dimensional
space, keeping in mind
the fact that when
we generalize what
happens in n-dimensional
space, the actual proofs become
messier, but the theory
remains very much the same.
I prefer to leave the messy
details to the exercises,
either optional or
required, depending
on how hard the
exercises may be.
But let me summarize
what the results are
for any n-dimensional
space, keeping
in mind we've proven
the results rigorously
for the case n equals 2.
The generalization is this.
If I have an n-dimensional
vector space,
v, with respect to a
particular basis, u1 up to un,
and if alpha 1 up to alpha n
are n vectors chosen from v so
that they are linear
combinations of the us,
say, in the traditional
way that we've written this
all the time, it turns
out the following.
That the determinant of
alpha 1 up to alpha n--
first of all, it's conventional
and convenient to write
the determinant as if
it were a matrix, only
replacing the square brackets
by sort of absolute value
signs-- vertical lines.
What we do is, notice that alpha
1 is written as an n-tuple,
a11 up to a1n.
In other words, the first
rule of the determinant
represents alpha 1 as an n-tuple
vector relative to the basis
u1 up to un.
And a similar thing holds
for alpha 2 through alpha n.
And you may remember, I
told you what the recipe
was when we were dealing with--
I told you what
the recipe was when
we were dealing with cross
products and the like.
And the idea is simply this.
What you do is is you start
in the upper left-hand corner
writing a plus sign.
Then you alternate going
along rows and columns
in any order you want writing
plus, minus, plus, minus,
et cetera, plus, minus,
plus, minus, et cetera.
Pick any row or
column that you want.
And then you go down that
row or column factoring
out a particular term, the plus
sign telling you to take out
the term as it is, the minus
the term and change its sign,
and you multiply that term
by the n minus 1 by n
minus 1 matrix that's
left when you strike out the row
and column in which that term
occurs.
Now, if that still sounds
like a tongue-twister,
let's do this in terms of
a specific semi-abstract,
semi-concrete,
four-dimensional case.
Namely, let's suppose v is a
four-dimensional vector space
relative to a particular
basis, u1, u2, u3, and u4.
Suppose alpha 1, alpha
2, alpha 3, and alpha 4
are these four specific
vectors of v. And again--
I can't keep emphasizing
this too much,
even though I hope some of you
are bored because you know it
so well--
it's always understood
when I write this
that the components are
relative to u1, u2, u3, u4.
For example, this is 3u1
plus 5u2 plus 7u3 plus 2u4.
Now, the traditional way of
expanding this determinant
is you write down the
rows as the n-tuples.
See, you write down-- this is
your first row, second row,
third row, fourth row.
So you notice that
the determinant
is an n by an array of numbers
that you have four vectors.
Each vector is a
4-tuple, and this is
how you get this determinant.
Now, what do we do next?
Let's say, for the
sake of argument,
I elect to expand this
determinant along the top row.
I first take the 1 out.
Because it has a plus
sign, that comes out as 1.
I multiply that by
the 3 by 3 determinant
that's left when I strike out
the row and column in which 1
appears.
I take out 2, but make it a
minus, because of the signature
here, and multiply that by
the 3 by 3 determinant that's
left when I strike out the row
and column in which 2 appears.
I factor out 1 as it is,
and multiply that by the 3
by 3 determinant
that's left when
I strike out the row and
column in which this 1 appears.
And finally, I take
out this minus 1
and change its sign, because
of this minus code over here.
In other words, this comes out
as a plus 1 multiplied by the 3
by 3 determinant that's
left when I strike out
the row and column in
which minus 1 appears in.
And to make a long story
short, all we're saying
is that this 4 by
4 determinant can
be written as a sum of
four 3 by 3 determinants,
namely, this, which is
precisely what I was
saying the long way up here.
Now, what we say is,
each of these 3 by 3s
can be written as three 2 by 2s.
Namely, I can factor out--
say again, I'm going
across the top row.
I can pick any
row or any column,
but let me stick to the top
row, like we did in i, j,
and k, for the time being.
But this becomes what?
5 times this 2 by 2
matrix, minus 3 times
this 2 by 2 matrix, plus 1
times this 2 by 2 matrix.
In other words, this
expression here.
I can now do that
for each of these.
So each of the 3 by 3s
gives me three 2 by 2s.
So altogether, I
would have 12 2 by 2s
and go through this whole
mess to compute this thing.
And this can be very,
very difficult, sure.
This was only a
four-dimensional case.
Imagine trying to
apply this technique
for a 10-dimensional
vector space,
for the sake of argument.
It turns out that that
recipe that we called
theorem two gives us
a tie-in between row
reduced matrices and a quick
way to compute determinants.
For example, let's
suppose we still
wanted to compute the same
determinant that we've
written down over here.
Let's call that-- let's
write it again over here.
What we already
know is, if I were
to replace the second vector
by the second minus twice
the first, the determinant
does not change.
That's what theorem two said.
If you replace one
vector by itself
plus a scalar
multiple of another,
you don't change
the determinant.
Similarly, if I were
to replace this vector
by three times the
first vector, I
would still have the
same determinant.
And finally, if I were
to replace this vector
by three times the
first vector, I
would still have the
same determinant.
I don't know if you've noticed
what I've been driving at.
But wasn't what I was saying
here the same computational
steps that one goes through
in row reducing a matrix?
In other words, let me
row reduce this matrix
so I get 0s every place,
say, in my first column,
except in the upper column.
By the way, notice
over here I always
have the habit of putting a 1
in the upper left-hand corner.
That's simply to
facilitate the arithmetic.
I hope by this stage of
the game you realize,
if this weren't a 1, I can
always divide through by it,
or what have you, and do
the arithmetic another way.
I just do this thing
for convenience.
But the important point is
that this determinant is now
equal to this determinant.
And be very careful.
Notice, if these had been
matrices-- in other words,
if I had put square brackets
here and had made these
matrices--
we would call the two matrices
row equivalent but different
matrices.
Notice, the determinant
is a number.
And what we're saying
is that the number named
by this determinant is
equal to the number named
by this determinant--
equal.
Here's the key point.
I now notice that I have
three 0s in the first column.
I, therefore, elect to
expand this determinant
along the first column.
Why do I do this?
Well, let's take a look.
First of all, I get a
1 multiplied by this 3
by 3 determinant that's left
when I strike out the row
and column in which 1 appears.
The beauty is that when I form
the other three determinants, 3
by 3 determinants, they're all
going to be multiplied by 0.
For example, over here,
I factor out-- well
minus 0, which is still 0.
What do I multiply that by?
I multiply that by
the 3 by 3 determinant
that's left when I
strike out the row
and column that this
0 appears in, namely,
the 3 by 3 determinant,
2, 1, minus 1,
minus 1, 4, 5, 2, 3, 4.
But since that's
being multiplied by 0,
the product will be 0.
To make a long story short,
to evaluate this determinant,
it's simply what?
Plus 1 times this
3 by 3 determinant.
I put the 1 in parentheses
here to indicate that I really
factored that 1 out.
But really what we're saying
is that this 4 by 4 determinant
has the same value as
this 3 by 3 determinant.
And now, I row reduce
I replace the second row, in
other words, the second vector,
by the second plus the first,
the third by the third minus
twice the first.
I now wind up with this
3 by 3 determinant.
Since I don't change the
value of the determinant
when I replace one
vector by itself
plus a scalar
multiple of another,
then notice very quickly
that what happens over here
is that these two
determinants are equal.
Again, I elect to expand along
the first column factoring out
the plus 1 being left with the
determinant whose entries are
5, 8, 1, 1.
And the other two terms
contribute nothing,
because the coefficient is 0.
But I already know
how to expand--
I've proven that-- how to expand
the 2 by 2 matrix, determinant.
That's just going to be what?
5 minus 8 or minus 3.
And that's how this shortcut
row reduction works--
much, much more elegantly than
the brute force technique.
And by the way, this
is the technique
used in most, if
not all, computers
in determining the determinant
of a set of n vectors
in an n-dimensional
vector space.
Well, as I say, this was
meant as an overview.
I hope you now see the overall
picture of what determinants
are all about.
And in the exercises,
I will try to give you
some more sophisticated
and elaborate details.
Next time what we
will do is talk
about an application
of how determinants
are used in certain
aspects of vector spaces.
In particular, we're going
to talk about something
called eigenvalues or
eigenvectors, but more
about that next time.
Until next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.